welcome to this blitz game yep I'm I'm
just great yeah I just screwed up the
screen area totally so I couldn't stop
the video for about 20 seconds okay
let's let's play something I know the
maroc see bind is always nice I have a
huge body of experience with that let's
see what happens we should be simian
night see to this is my my foot line
keeping pieces on the board it's very
often somewhat awkward would like to
meet I is playing this very quickly
seems to know something about it maybe
yeah bit should be six is what they
usually do here attacking c4 then I play
95 the night on a three looks a bit
weird but b3 is not a move you want to
play at the moment as b5 can be very
annoying okay the queen is not well
placed on c7 because of 95 at some point
this is why I play rook see one ok bb5
you're never going to play really very
often I play rugby one going out of this
long diagonal I wonder if this is an
idea here on if it is a loss of time I
can let's see what he sought his play
next black does not really have anything
great b5 Maya mean I'm covering this
four times square it's not going to be
played
yeah the general problem in the
structures that black suffers from lack
of space what he would love to do is to
exchange some pieces simply to get more
maneuvering space something like one
pair of nights or to pay off nights
would be nice and let's say light
squared Bishop sir or now dark squared
Bishop for that matter just trade off
something to to get some some more space
um here interesting 95 is the is the
most obvious way to play here still
let's not the only one I can also yeah
maybe maybe now be three I mean be five
is not going to be played could be five
earlier was strictly because there was
some district gem on the C file I can
show you that after the game that was
see if you play b3 here this b5 takes
Queen c7 and the nights are hanging in
the sea farm ok so I'm jumping back to
them to the current position yeah now
now we come to the point where black is
somewhat running out of running out of
moves ok we are 95 now or maybe or what
can play night see two can play night
see to first yeah why not
so no 95 that's that's quite nice yeah
actually both is good both captures
I'm going to take with us I'm very often
BNC porn BNC rook a better a better
place for the C porn recapture but
hereafter he has played h5 I think this
he captures is a bit more interesting
simply because he has weakened the
kingside a bit if the pawn is on h7 the
movie 5 is much more interesting for
black here and you cannot really do that
as g6 is this is so weakened if I've
takes every g6 as terrible so I'm black
I really has some problem here what
should he play cannot move any of the
pawns really now I'm just playing slide
strengthening moves and then decide on a
concrete plan yeah fyf 5s sir is a good
idea attacking the the weekend King side
structure may be here five or six young
it's not it's not particularly
attractive but at least it's playable
that was very quickly played remarkable
I get a five now and I don't see any
tricks here when the rookie three ism
something to watch out for with Bishop
default pinning against the King always
something to be careful about when you
move the f-bomb yeah i thought we should
a four-year or bishop to h6 just for the
tech i got and then then it's got this
check probably that's not a bad move
here rookie five maybe a relatively good
defense but but still queen is seven
quite quite annoying really and I just
need to get a five this is this is a
good control were threatening each five
now
don't see any particular counterplay for
black now 95 maybe 95 I'm not sure that
I can take on f5 well it's not very
comfortable for black in any case maybe
I could have played Queen F or even and
just take a five next yeah that's
possible maybe this was better you okay
if I take a five now does he have a pin
some sort of pin don't see it okay well
still i'm learning take here Knight f6
Queen f3 f3 is a good good place for the
Queen can play 94 m but not sure how
problematic this is we should d 4 95
maybe
well that's not that's not so great I
really thought this this would be better
we can take f2 now what was this oh that
was a bad idea
hmm so what download time yeah that was
just very badly played him what I did oh
this is helpful getting Queens off my
king was really insecure black forfeits
all time yeah not a very logical end to
all of this but okay I'm pretty much
done with the increment subject yeah
this was just bad play I mean up here up
to here I'm pretty satisfied why it
should be very good him I didn't I
didn't want to play Bishop deform maybe
this is just right I mean this is pretty
much picks up as an exchange but it
didn't feel right to give up the dark
squared Bishop p.m. computer just says
plus two and that's it but ok but i
think i think this was actually a better
move attacking here and if i get f 5 i'm
just much much better yet here i don't
know it's still good oops it is still
good but it's not easy to play yeah here
plate Bishop f1 I just forgot that you
can take on f2
yeah should before I mean I saw this but
I was scared of this computer just gives
this and wins yeah it looks this this
look you want stuff looks very scary but
as usual you cannot really impress a
computer yeah I already lost track here
and here it starts to to get slightly
slightly tricky when the computer is
still convinced that white is much
better I'm not really oh yeah he could
have taken just winning for black now I
came again queen d 5 ATM i was glad that
the queens are traded i actually thought
that this would be good with Bishop g4
threatened this seems to be a boat equal
according to the comp Queen f3 and 3d
one yeah very very difficult to play
yeah oh this I was pretty satisfied with
and f5 oh this is good but okay maybe I
look everyone rook everyone is good yeah
I always had some some doubts about I
cannot take it 3i just take at 5pm yeah
so I applied it correctly but I followed
up in the wrong way alright thanks for
watching